what do you what do you say about
the adaptive quality of forgetting so
for example
some people who have unbelievable
memories for
events in their lives like episodic
memory they
are often leading horrible lives you can
see
you can see there's a few documentaries
on this where they
remember exactly what they're eating 10
years ago on a certain day and the
weather and so on
and they they see their natural
penchant from memory as being a curse in
a sense because
they remember all their mistakes and
this one lady said
you know how you ruminate at night so
she was speaking to the camera how you
say i wish i could have said this
then and so on so imagine doing that for
every conversation for the past 20 years
then i was watching
i don't know you probably would know
much
you're probably correct now as for
there's this person who
apparently has the highest iq in america
now that's like
who knows because iq at the extremely
high range
you can't actually test it in the way
that people think you can
whatever his name is chris langan you
know i'm sure chris langan said that
he doesn't have a great memory and that
what he thinks
intelligence is is the
proper selection of what you remember so
if you can remember a whole book
so what it matters like you mentioned
for your goals so what do you say to
that
about memories memory is great
but at the same time your brain one's
brain is set up to forget
for a specific reason so that means your
memory has to be matched with
with adaptive forgetting so it has to be
adaptive memory and adapter forgetting
so how do you balance that like what do
you say to
someone who has an obscene memory
right well superior autobiographical
memory is a very interesting topic and
the the you know the full decisions
about what it is and how it works aren't
out
but there are a couple of cases
where skeptics of superior
autobiographical memory have done some
research
and they have seen that there's a
commonality among some of these cases
because if it isn't a sort of cervantism
that's involved there is an
ocd level of self-rumination
and often journaling so i don't know if
you're if you're referring to jill price
but jill price
it was a highly publicized figure uh the
book is called the woman who can't
forget
which i think was ghost written for her
or you know with her
but in any case it's an interesting book
to read but what the book doesn't talk
about but that was discovered by some
people who are a little skeptical of
this is that she's an obsessive
journaler
right and um often rehearsing
again and again and again what was
journaled the day before
now i don't think that the obsessive
journaling accounts for all of this but
i think it
it's a clue to something that's going on
in some people
and it's interesting that it's
autobiographical memory
it's not clear that it's the episodic
that is as strong
um although obviously they blur
um in any case i don't know but i don't
know that it's clear that they have
somehow
lost adaptive forgetting in ways that
others haven't i think it's
maybe a little bit more clear that
there's a commonal
commonality in terms of rumination that
is leading
to exactly the things that memory
competitors do or people who use memory
techniques do
which is a kind of forced ocd
where you're rigging serial positioning
effect to give everything primacy and
recency so that you can remember it
longer using what's called fondrestorf
effect which is you exaggerate it
and so you can look at cases like jill
price and you know with all
due humility that i don't know or never
talk to her and overly seen interviews
with her
but it seems like she's exaggerating a
lot of the events in her life
which would lead to them not only being
more memorable but causing more more
suffering
and we i've done that to myself you know
and i think we've all had that
experience that sting of something you
said
and you can't just you just can't let it
go well
what is it that you can't let it go is
it because you constantly rehearse it
and
compound its value so that it shocks you
more and more and becomes more and more
painful or
is it i don't know it's not necessarily
clear
but to answer your question directly
forgetting is normal
it's sort of healthy but it's also not
necessarily the case that you have to
forget anything
you could work on it
but there will be a forgetting curve at
least that's what we see in the science
and i think we see it in
in our practical lives if you don't use
it you will lose it
and even in english the years i lived in
germany
i started to experience what's called
linguistic de-skilling my english skills
went down and i noticed them going back
up after i moved to australia it was
just
just the strangest thing but that's
interesting you know i
i wouldn't say that my english is is
profoundly good in any
respect at all but it had gone down
noticeably and i noticed it after living
in an english-speaking country again
that it went back up